Whatever you have to do, you do
however long it takes.
Promise me
you'll find your way home
Furiosa
Give me this
Promise
Lie down.
Start your engines.
Ontario, stop.
The darkest of the angels.
The question is,
do you have it in you to make it epic?
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Happy Brazil Comic-Con weekend
There's a ton of trailer footage.
This is for Furiosa, The next Mad Max movie set
before the events of Fury Road.
as you can tell, it's all about the origin story
of the Furiosa character,
started by Charlize Theron, played by Anya Taylor-Joy
in her younger form.
It takes place about 15 years
before the events of Fury Road, and it looks bonkers.
It's Chris Hemsworth
versus Immortan Joe versus Furiosa.
So this is like the three way battle
going on during the trailer.
We'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel,
this is just the beginning.
There's a bunch of trailers coming
like House of the Dragon Season
2 trailer, The Boys Season 4 Trailer
I will do videos for everything this weekend,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
The synopsis for the movie reads As the world
Fell, young Furiosa is snatched from the green place
of many mothers and falls into the hands
of a great biker horde led by the warlord Dementus.
That's Chris Hemsworth's character
They put him in a prosthetic nose.
So I think he doesn't look quite
as much like Thor. Like, is that Thor?
What is Thor done now?
What's going on in this apocalypse?
can we make Chris Hemsworth look as ugly as possible?
sweeping through the wasteland.
They come across the Citadel,
presided over by the Immortan Joe,
who was the main villain of Mad Max Fury Road.
He's also still the main villain of this.
but the whole idea is
that you have Chris Hemsworth's warlord Dementus
fighting Immortan Joe for control of the Citadel
during the movie in Furiosa, sort of cop between them
trying to survive long enough so that she can escape
and try to find her home that she was stolen from.
that's basically what the synopsis continues to say.
Like while the two tyrants war
for dominance of the Citadel, Furiosa
must survive many trials as she puts together
the means to find her way home.
there a couple of big time jumps during the trailer
because they do cover her origin story
when she was very young.
But when she's like the full Anya TAYLOR-JOY
adult version
of the character
that's 15 years before the events of Fury Road.
end, I think part of the idea in them
calling it Furiosa with the subtitle A Mad Max Saga
is because the Mad Max character
probably will not appear in the movie,
or if he is maybe like in the post credits scene.
otherwise they would probably call the movie Mad Max.
Furiosa.
I do not think that Tom Hardy's
version of Mad Max is going to appear during the movie
famously, on set,
he and Charlize Theron got into a bunch of battles.
There was a bunch of bad blood between them on set.
They've since made up
because the movie was like nine years ago.
That's how long it's been since Fury Road came out.
it takes George Miller a while
to cook this stuff in the oven.
Like, what is he cooking?
But for those of you that have been clamoring
for something like this, like something as big
and weird, that has nothing to do with Marvel or DC
or like big comic book movies,
this is what you've been waiting for.
Does it not look like it is going to be totally crazy
in the best possible way?
I did get a bunch of George Miller, Chris Hemsworth,
the other people talking about the movie.
So I'll use that later in the video.
But just starting at the beginning of the trailer
footage, working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs, wtf moments in references
to the other Mad Max movies.
There are a couple of Easter eggs
here in the trailer that you probably detected
like a couple of mirrored shots,
a couple of familiar things.
so at the beginning of the trailer they start on on you
taylor-joy's adult version
of Furiosa walking away from her bike,
looking out into the wasteland.
This is meant to mirror
the shot from the very beginning of Mad Max Fury Road
with Tom Hardy's
Mad Max character doing the exact same thing.
They cut it with the voiceover of what sounds like
might be her mother telling her to find her way home.
Like, no matter what you do, find your way home
eventually, Later, in the trailer,
we see what looks like her home,
that she was stolen from.
They call it the green place of many mothers.
And I think the idea is that
it just gets raided by warlords.
Immortan Joe, this dementus character,
other random warlords in the wasteland
for breeding purposes,
the land of many mothers, quote unquote.
there were a lot of women at the Citadel
during Fury Road.
So I think part of the idea is that
most of them get stolen from either other places
or they just grow up in that environment,
not sure why she's left her bike.
It might be because it
ran out of gas. in the wasteland.
The two most precious resources are like gasoline
and just basically water.
normally I would just say water,
but like everything, they have runs on gasoline.
that's part of the whole metaphor of George Miller's
Mad Max movies.
It's sort of like the downfall of society.
So that's why you don't see any of the characters,
any of the Mad Max movies
using any kind of solar power or electric power
or anything like that.
Then they have what looks like dementus' biker
gang with his bikers.
Furiosa
seems like she becomes one of those at some point.
Like he's the person that steals her
from the green place of many mothers
where she originally grew up and they give us a big
info dump like a bunch of exposition
with these titles
flying at the screen, explaining sort of the backstory
of what happened before the events of this movie,
when it says 45 years after the collapse,
that's basically meant to have taken place
between the first two Mad Max movies like Mad Max
and then The Road Warrior.
So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute, didn't Tom Hardy play
the Mad Max character in Fury Road 15 years after this?
The timeline doesn't totally make sense.
the funny way that George Miller addressed
this is that he said he didn't really care
too much about the really specific
internal canon of his Mad Max movies.
He would just focus on telling, like,
really interesting stories with the new movies.
so their little details are like
the timeline doesn't add up or something like that.
That's on purpose.
George Miller intended it to be that way.
is sort of like the Spider-Man Marvel eight years later
kind of issue that cropped up and people are like,
Wait a minute, The Avengers battle didn't happen
eight years ago, Like the timeline is wrong.
the Marvel people care more about that internal
timeline way, way more than George Miller does.
when it says Furiosa is going to devote
the rest of her life to finding her way home.
Obviously by the events of Mad Max Fury Road
that still has not happened.
I love the description here. This is her odyssey.
It makes it sound very, very old school
like very Greek odyssey.
Odysseus.
this is the very young version of Furiosa, who's
just been stolen from her home with a little teddy bear
and a younger version of Chris Hemsworth's tremendous
character talking to the rest of his biker gang.
notice.
He says, Lady and gentlemen,
because she's the only woman that's there with them.
it's not totally clear why he stole her from her home.
Maybe it was initially for breeding purposes.
maybe it was because of happenstance.
Like, maybe she just got swept up in their raid.
he looks absolutely bonkers.
And because this was filmed down in Australia,
he can use his natural Australian accent.
so, even though he is putting on a special voice
for the movie, it's
much closer to his natural
speaking voice than his voice as Thor.
I cannot wait to see some of the Thor memes
when this comes out though,
like what is going on They're couple of shots
from across the movie in different places.
I think this monster truck is meant to belong to Chris
Hemsworth's character,
George Miller talked about a couple different cars
during the movie.
And I think the idea is that some of the characters
will get a bunch of different cars at different points.
they're a bunch of Immortan
Joe's men with his gasoline truck.
then we see younger Immortan Joe versus
Chris Hemsworth's Dementus
this person on the bike
that looks like it's raiding Immortan Joe's gasoline
truck is probably part of DeMint's gang, It seems like
when he's vying for control of the Citadel,
they find the gasoline truck
and they try to raid it just like anybody else.
Any other group of raiders would try to do
just because gasoline is so precious.
Notice he's putting the black makeup on her forehead
like we saw her wear during Mad Max Fury Road.
And there's that wheel behind her, too.
It seems like that room for Mad Max Fury Road
that they all took the wheels from
when they went on missions not sure what's happening
to Chris Hemsworth's dementus character here
Like this is Giant Fire.
It just seems like
he's in the middle of some big battle.
this is meant to be furious.
His home, the green place of many mothers, Naturally,
you see a ton of women notice.
They're running with a bunch of machetes,
a bunch of guns.
It just seems like they're in the middle of a raid Not
totally sure what's going on in this scene here, too.
In the middle of the night in the wasteland.
this just seems like some person
that takes Furiosa under his wing when she's younger.
maybe some person that she gets close to
inside the Citadel, like inside Immortan Joe's group.
the problem with that, though,
inside the Mad Max universe, that's sort of
like a death sentence
for anybody that gets close to the main character.
Usually they wind up dying,
especially any time it seems like to people experience
like a happy moment, like, something really bad
is about to happen here to undercut this.
this just seems like it happens at some point during
the movie when she's working with the biker gang.
this seems like her driving one of Immortan Joe's cars.
this is actually gas town.
The refinery that they referenced during Mad Max
Fury Road that they were supposed to be on their way to
when she was helping all those women escape
it's pretty much exactly what you think it is.
It's like a refinery that's just near the citadel
where they get their gasoline from.
just another shot of Immortan Joe.
this seems like Furiosa doing the same kind of chant
that they did
during Fury Road when they went on missions.
this just seems like another shot of dementus
This biker gang raiding Immortan Joe's gasoline truck.
notice. It's the middle of the day.
And they're also on their way to Gastown
Then we see Furiosa
attacking a bunch of people
and also her with her mechanical arms,
like she's already had her arm replaced at this point,
Not exactly sure how that's going to go down.
It'll be interesting to see because in a bunch of other
scenes during the trailer, she has both of her arms.
then they end with a shot of her with her
bike underneath Immortan
Joe's gas truck, which might just be part of the way
their raid goes down.
this is probably just a little bit earlier
in the movie.
one of the interesting things
I like the whole idea of the three way battle going,
like Furiosa is trying to survive Dementus
Chris Hemsworth's character versus Immortan Joe.
But Dementus does not appear
as far as we know, in Mad Max Fury Road.
So that probably means
that he winds up dying at some point during this movie.
and clearly Immortan Joe still rules over the citadel
when that is happening in the later movie
there's a bunch of stuff going on in the trailer
so if you recognize any Easter eggs
for any of the other Mad Max movies
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Right now,
the movie is scheduled to come out May 24th next year.
that will actually come out
pretty close to Dune 2, which is now coming out
a little bit earlier in the year in March.
so the couple of really cool movies
coming out early next year
but like I said, this weekend is Brazil Comic-Con.
They're a bunch of big trailers
that'll be dropping tomorrow I'll be doing videos for
How's the Dragon Season two trailer
and then probably a boys season four trailer.
I'm not sure exactly what time they're dropping,
so just be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
I'll do videos form as fast as possible.
click here for that House
The Dragon Season 3 trailer video
and click here for The Boys Season 4 trailer video.
I'll update the links for those
As soon as I post those videos
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!